accepting our invitation to address the
European Parliament as part of our this
is Europe series of debates
these have been difficult days for
Europe and it is time to reaffirm our
values
the war in Ukraine is continuing
unabatedly pushed back onto the
battlefield the Kremlin has increasingly
turned its war machine into onto
innocent civilians weaponizing basic
Commodities in a desperate attempt to
get Ukraine and Europe to concede I am
proud of our clear United and unwavering
response because our values our freedom
our Liberty our democracy our
non-negotiable
the people of Ukraine are fighting
precisely for these values and yet
this does not mean that the consequences
are not being felt people in Slovenia
are worried people in Europe are worried
they are worried about heating their
homes about getting to the end of the
months about paying their bills and this
is the time when European leadership is
needed the most
this means common actions solidarity in
gas supply and the creation of the
credible energy single Market this is
how we address our citizens concerns in
the short term but we also need to be
clear
our sourest way of achieving full energy
Independence is by speeding up our green
transition and this has become just as
much about security as it is about
climate ambition it is not the time to
backtrack prime minister with two-thirds
of slovenia's power generation being CO2
free and by further pledging to increase
the use of renewable energy by 2030 your
country has been showing leadership in
this field what is more by increasing
interconnection with its neighbors
Slovenia is well on track to improve its
energy resilience and I look forward to
seeing the same commitment reflected by
all member states within our Union prime
minister I also see Slovenian leadership
when it comes to accelerating the
integration process of the western
Balkans and here I speak more
specifically about Bosnia and
Herzegovina this year we have already
seen with Ukraine and with Moldova what
a powerful message EU candidacy stated
this can give and my hope for us is to
have this same courage also with our
friends in Bosnia and has a governor
dear prime minister dear Robert the
floor is yours
foreign
esteemed members of the European
Parliament
citizens of the European Union
I know that later attendance will surely
be higher so I will take this as an
opportunity for a warm-up for what's to
come at 11 and I hope I will be able to
be as efficient as possible it is a
great honor for me to be able to address
the European Parliament all of the
European citizens
because I wish to
discuss our common European future
a common future based on the power of
unity the power of cooperation and the
power
of solidarity
I come from a small member country and
I'm well aware of the fact that only
when we are unified on the basis of our
powers and R values and when everyone
can contribute their best we can form a
community that will function well and be
successful and when this community is
United and decisive
it can shift the limits of possible
and I believe that today the European
Union and Europe as a whole is facing a
great challenge in terms of how much
power it has in addressing these
historical trials that it faces
after having lived through two years of
the covet pen Dynamic and I won't be
discussing this today
we were forced due to the Russian
aggression to face a situation without
precedence after the second World War
this is a situation in which all of the
international standards and values are
being violated
the sovereignty of
different countries is being violated
and there is military aggression that is
completely unbased
in addition to other complications this
aggression also affects all of us all of
the citizens of the EU as well as
its economy
not only the energy crisis the energy
surges
all of this has led to a great economic
crisis today especially because of the
price hikes in all areas
and record breaking inflation and that
is why today I would like to discuss
three areas
I will focus on
the energy policy and the green
transition this is also
related to my background but I will also
discuss the rule of law as well as our
geopolitical efforts
in which Slovenia plays a small but
important part
dear ladies dear gentlemen
let me give you just pay
itself in order to
fully understand why well I will address
energy
as the major topic during my speech
for the last 15 years I was working at
the Energy Company the company that I
founded
and I
was running as a CEO
the company that grew from zero
up to three billions in revenues the
company that was the largest energy
Trader in Southern and Eastern Europe
the company that grew from zero to the
largest supplier of electricity in
Slovenia and the company which at the
latest years was also the largest
provider of
solar power plants meaning that we did
embark on the
invest in universe as well
having said that let's switch to the
main topic and that is energy
it is totally clear to everyone that
over dependence
on one guest source which is from Russia
led to the weaponization of that
particular energy source during last
year
and that the consequences of that
weaponization we are facing right now
but
even though the lack of supply
was rightly addressed
by the Swift action both by the
Parliament and commission during the
last weeks meaning that just by the
combining the three factors which is
being able to reduce the Demand Being
able to find new sources from friendly
countries and being able
to keep the pipelines open
throughout the Europe
by implementing the solidarity clause
we were able to cover for the energy
needs
but it was not enough to address the
prices
and this is one topic that I always
emphasize whenever I speak to my
colleagues at European Council and that
is that yes a lot has been done
but more needs to be done as well in the
future and this week
is crucial in that regard
so either we address properly the high
energy prices
and when I say properly means decisively
and when I say decisively we need to
implement regulatory changes in the
market mechanisms because the internal
energy Market at the moment
I will not say it's not working I will
say it's been
worked by the speculative money but for
their own profits and not for the
benefits of the population of Europe
and this is where the responsibility of
the European Council comes into light
because it's up to us to address this
issue in the proper manner and we
already asked commission once
to come up with a set of rule set of
measures which will adequately address
this issue
and I cannot say that I'm happy with
what the commission has come up with
it will not work it's not enough
we will need to be more decisive in
order to reduce the volatility on the
markets we will need to be more decisive
to eliminate cap spikes price spikes and
we need to be more decisive when it
comes to the gas caps price guess price
gaps sorry
and it's
the energy ministers sit in the Council
of today
and I certainly hope and urge that they
will come to a common decision
by whatever means
in order to show the unity not to the
population but to the markets because we
need to show the unity to these
speculative Traders
and remember I was I made my living by
doing that so I know what I'm talking
about so we need to show them a clear
message and unity that we will not be
led drained we will not let them drain
our budgets we will not let them drain
the global competitiveness of our
industry for their profits
it's a very important message and that's
why I'm repeating it all over the place
and uh I'm doing it right now
but the future doesn't stop today and
doesn't stop this winter so we need to
look forward onward and uh
the green transition
is actually not just the only way
forward but it is also the only way that
addresses the three issues
simultaneously
it does improve and it does bring
autonomy
Independence
energy Independence to Europe it is the
only way to energy Independence
it does mitigate climate
change
because that's the only way how to
reduce the impact of energy on climate
and it also at the end of the day it
also brings lower energy prices
so we do address all three issues
simultaneously and that means that again
we cannot linger we need to move as bold
and as ambitious as possible if that
means
speed up the permitting process
well yes if that means building more not
just interconnectors but more
gas and pipe and power lines yes we do
need more power lines at all levels
we can put them underground but we need
them and we need more storage capacity
as well
to enable the grids to connect more
Renewables
and this is really the only way forward
and by if we act bold and decisive and
we if we link the wind potential of
North with some potential of the South
put some Hydro in the mix and some
storage in between
yeah in the next 10 to 15 years we could
be totally renewable in Europe
it is a vision that it's doable okay it
might take us five more years than that
but it's doable and that's the most
important message and for that reason
not just because of the
energy crisis that we're facing now we
are really we owe it we owe it to our
children to do it now because it's
doable so there is absolutely no excuse
that we wait with our next steps when it
comes to that
um before entering politics while I was
tiered executive I was also the EU
climate pact Ambassador I was promoting
and
sincerely promoting it because I was
living I was for living I was doing the
energy trading but for my soul I was
promoting the
self-sustainable home Energy Systems the
systems where each of us that owns a
home can become totally independent on
himself
on on Earth with him or on hers or his
energy needs for all energy needs
electric vehicle
sunroof solar
heating heat pumps and the storage
by doing that
we helped
thousands and ten thousands of
households in Slovenia to become totally
independent from the existing crisis so
they are not just helping the
environment at the moment they are
totally independent on the energy Crisis
crisis
and the
the one thing that we are addressing all
the time when it comes to energy
transition we are always addressing
the how do we deal with the energy for
our
machines for our Technologies
but we are overlooking one important
thing
this is my second message we are
overlooking the where do how do we
address the energy that we need to fuel
our bodies which is food
foot system
that we are utilizing right now
is totally unsustainable
for our future
totally unless we change the food
production and food consumption
in a very thorough way
we will not be able to meet any
of the climate goals
because if the rest of the world would
follow in our steps we would need seven
planets
just to sustain the food consumption
which is obviously not something that
can be done
now of course each of us can start the
change in himself or herself
changing the diet
of course that's easy just switch from
let's let's meet I'm not saying no meat
but that's consume less meat let's
consume more plant-based food anyway
it's healthier but this is not the story
today
but in that way we will help the planet
and we will help our children as well
not just by teaching them how to be
healthier but also in teaching them how
to be sustainable
but that's individual Choice what is the
responsibility of the government or of
the authorities
the main responsibility is the building
of the awareness
scientific facts when it comes to food
plus plus this is important to enable
the choice
enable the choice of healthier food to
be available
in public systems that's what we did on
a small scale in Slovenia back home and
results are amazing
we didn't have to force anyone and 50
off
consumers at a particular facility
switched within a month on a totally
plant-based food
it was an individual choice
that was enabled
by the authorities
not enforced this is very important
going back to the the other thing where
the responsibility of the government is
even more of the authorities even more
crucial is of course rule of law
and when it comes to rule of law
uh
I will share a personal story with you
as you already know as you already
remember most probably I was minding my
own business earning lots of money and
being quite happy
up to a certain point when I realized
that the rule of law in Slovenia is just
being eaten away
by Me by the previous government
the judicial system was
slowly been weakened
the freedom of speech and the media
especially freedom of media
was being taken away
at a certain point of time again being
happy I just realized I don't want to
live in a country
where the rule of law is not existent
this is why I stepped into politics
this is why I stepped out of my comfort
zone not in my comfort zone and this is
why I stand here
and this is so important that and that's
why I realized that the rule of law is
not something to be negotiated about but
it's something to be enforced
and that that is the responsibility of
all of us that are in the political
system
by saying that
the one thing that the first thing that
comes to your mind once you
to have to make a decision whether you
stamped into politician role or not is
okay how do we deal with
all the exposure
the fake news exposure
hate speech exposure
because that's immediately what you get
once you decide to step into politics
and I'm not speaking about
uncoordinated or
spontaneous
fake news or spontaneous hate speech I'm
speaking about hate speech between which
is financed and instigate it
by the existing political forces or
lobbyists doesn't matter what you call
them
so I urge and I know that you've already
done some steps when it comes to hate
speech the parliament I know it's been
the council the European Council again
who was blocking who is blocking it but
I urge you to find new ways
new ways how to address the issue of
paid for
hate speech with a clear
clear goal and the goal is you know what
to keep the decent people out of
politics
that's really the goal
[Applause]
I know there is a fine balance between
the freedom of speech and the hate
speech the measures against one and
measures to really improve the freedom
of speech
and I'm pretty much sure you will know
how to strike the balance
because the freedom of speech especially
social media they do play an important
role when it comes to really bringing
things to our awareness that would
otherwise stay hidden
and in this regard I would like to
specially address the Iranian situation
which would not be noticed by anyone in
Europe because of the censorship unless
there would be social media
and the all the efforts done especially
by the Iranian Iranian women
and with their inventive non-violent
ways of protest protesting against the
brutality of the regime and for their
human rights or human rights Women
rights is something to be really proud
of
and to give them support as much as
possible so I urge you to be loud to
keep staying loud and to keep pointing
The Way Forward where they will be heard
also within this particular Parliament
I know a lots have been done and I urge
you to do more
let's show them
that we do know what our geopolitical
responsibility is
even though
most of the time
again within the European Council that's
not the case
he
okay I'll switch it back to Slovenia now
sorry
so this brings me to
my final point
and that is the geopolitical Endeavors
of Slovenia as well if anywhere then it
is in this field that the EU has shown
responsibility and unity in the event of
Russia's aggression against Ukraine and
I'm very grateful to all institutions
including the European Council
which have all shown that when the time
comes we certainly do know how to stand
United
we stood United also when we used the
strongest tool in the eu's Arsenal and
that is the enlargement process I very
much welcome
the decision on the part of all EU
institutions to have given both Ukraine
and Moldova
candidacy status
for membership of the EU and I welcome
all the Endeavors on the part of the EU
Parliament
to
bring the accession process forward and
to accelerate that process because EU
enlargement is as a matter of fact a
tool that we
very well know in Slovenia because we
are a relatively new member State I very
well remember the hope the hope for a
better future that the enlargement
process instilled in us and that is why
I understand very well
what sort of hope for a better future we
are giving the citizens of Ukraine and
Moldova by doing so and that is why I
call on you not
to hit the brakes on this process
and the same goes also for the Western
Balkans the Western Balkans
from the very beginning of the Russian
aggression have been
subject to a lot of pressure a lot of
propaganda
pressures aimed at
undoing the unity
of Europe
in terms of condemning Russia and
supporting Ukraine and that is why we
need to be very well aware of the fact
that this political tool can contribute
immensely to the stability of the region
and also to all of us remaining United
in our support
for Ukraine this is not just about
Bosnia Herzegovina but I do want to talk
about that country it is about all of
Western Balkans but Bosnia Herzegovina
is the country that
has been
a victim of aggression in the past as
well and that is why we owe it to Bosnia
Herzegovina today that we did not forget
about this country
just like we never want anyone to forget
about Ukraine years down the road
because that precisely is
the story we need to tell that we are
not just about giving signals at the
beginning
but that we bring stories to a
conclusion
this in Bosnia Herzegovina is a story
that started 20 years ago and hasn't
made steps forward now of course you
will ask well who should be the one
making the first step but Slovenia as a
relatively young member State can say
the following
the effect of EU membership is truly
transformative
we changed everything
membership of the EU changes a country
it changes the views of people and then
the people make sure that politics
change as well there's no other way
around it
counting on political structures to
change on their own is an illusion and
it will not yield results
what we
as European citizens have to work on is
making sure that our
fellow citizens in the western Balkans
need to believe that the only rightful
place for them is in Europe and then
they will make sure that changes will
happen in the political structures and
the political structures will then
accept this as something that has to be
done and that is when the rule of law
and democracy will also happen I do not
believe in a reverse order of things
that is why
in Slovenia all political structures
very strongly support
this process of being accelerated in
Bosnia Herzegovina and first and
foremost to give the inhabitants the
citizens of Bosnia Herzegovina to become
fully fledged European citizens
truly concluding now
Slovenia is a proud member of the
European family
and
it is in fact our great satisfaction
that we will be able to participate in
building Europe's future not only
together with the existing EU member
states but with all of Europe
we are of the belief that this is the
path that is going to lead not only to
peace but also to prosperity and Welfare
for all citizens all inhabitants of
Europe
thank you very much
thank you very much prime minister golop
and now we'll have the first round of
political groups starting with the Epp
group Paolo ramjan
okay
dear president
dear prime minister golub
let me warmly welcome you
in such a better moment for this
Parliament
Slovenia was the first country of former
Yugoslavia to join European Union
these stands
and should stand
as an example and the role model for the
Western Balkans and I must congratulate
Slovenia on its great integration
process that you have just described as
a great example for the whole region and
for all Europe
secondly congratulations on your new
president the first female president
despite she is not from our political
family
this is always a very positive and
Progressive step towards equality and
that should be here naturally uh point
of order
we have however some concerns including
on rule of law
which we must share and which is also
the point of these debates
first
Slovenia itself has suffered from
internal border sex before but now we
hear that you may consider introducing
internal border checks of your own after
Croatia joins Schengen
this would send the worst possible
signals especially after the council
rejected the accession of Romania and
Bulgaria if it happens the European
Parliament will be ready to scrutinize
any individual violation of our freedom
of movement in Slovenia or elsewhere in
Europe
second there are some concerns regarding
the rule of law
we are paying close attention to the
changing of laws ruling the media
landscape in Slovenia than in a rather
unusual and Urgent procedure
and let me tell you that the resignation
of the Interior Minister after
allegations of political pressure
regarding the police is also traveling
hi
who so often criticize here recent
developments in Spain or even in my own
country regarding concentration of the
power of police
I have to mention this case here as well
does these not trigger a rule of law
alert
when we speak about interference in
police commands
finally Slovenia is an example in the
support to Ukraine in the current war in
humanitarian financial and Military AIDS
as you have pointed out however it is
concerning that the members of European
Parliament that support your government
did not support the resolution of this
house recognizing Russia as a regime
sponsor of terrorism
all you assess these reluctance to
support Ukraine in no possible ways
your fellow slovene slave
famous satirize the geographical
divisions in Europe by pointing out what
separates the Balkans from mythiliropra
but those divisions must be behind us
the server of the Danube do not separate
Earth just like the denipro does not
divide Ukraine Europe is large enough
for us all Europe is more than a
continent it is an idea and it is also
an idea in slovene and left by the
sloving slovenians
even though today we meet in Strasbourg
let me recall a small piece of Brussels
near the Schumann roundabout not too far
from the European Parliament stands a
memorial with the first line of your
National anthemarati
God's blessing on All Nations
in this difficult winter in these
difficult times let these words these
Slovenian words
this often by the great French president
Echo throughout Europe may all our
Nations thrive
thank you very much Mr angel
now on behalf of the snd group Milan
brigels
foreign thank you madam president
dear prime minister
esteemed commissioner members of the
European Parliament
this is Europe
I am pleased that Slovenia and the
government of Robert Globe through this
debate and their engagement on the
European stage have proven that Slovenia
is part of the core of Europe and its
efforts for a more cohesive and
solidarity-based EU
for a European Union at the service of
its people
the sincere commitment to these values
is best revealed in times of great
trials in the aftermath of the pandemic
with the war on our doorstep and the
energy crisis
Slovenia has actively engaged in the
search for a joint European solution to
the energies crisis because as a small
country it understands very well that
the solution can only be based on Unity
solidarity and European values prime
minister I would like to encourage you
to continue these efforts and ensure
that Slovenia bought at home and at the
European level adopts additional
measures to reduce household costs and
provide support to small and
medium-sized Enterprises
at the same time the burden of
solidarity for the most vulnerable needs
to be carried by all sectors from the
energy and pharmaceutical sectors to the
banking sector
which have generated huge profits during
times of crises
I'm convinced that we can make it
together but also that we can show the
countries that are waiting to join the
union that we are on their side and that
we can support them
with the serious situation in the
Balkans and the war in Ukraine our
message must be clear Europe
and thus the European Union is and will
be the home of all those who wish to
live in a democracy in Freedom and in
peace thank you half of the renewed
group I give the floor to Stefan
sejonnet's group chat
um
thank you very much Madam president
prime minister ladies and gentlemen
since May Slovenia has impressed us with
its new European commitment
it has also become a role model for us
to follow when it comes to integration
you mentioned that we're very proud to
have you in our political family in
renew environmental transformation and
New Economic appeal are at the heart of
your government and the actions taken
fully in line with European climate
objectives of sovereignty
in a way you have put Slovenia back at
the heart of Europe
now your institutional work is
welcomed unanimously by Civil Society
Civic rights organizations and the
authoritarian slippery slope has come to
an end a state TV has become independent
again the justice system can do its work
against a calmer backdrop over the last
few months with you at the Helm of the
government
and vote after vote it has shown that
the populist experience of your
predecessor Mr yansa was a complete
failure economically socially and
politically now what has just been said
by you Mr Rangel doesn't surprise me
we have heard Epp slander against
Slovenia since the defeat in May MEPS or
Epp MEPS are officially pro-european but
they have often supported and even
provide excuses for Mr yansha's insults
on social on the social networks and
I think that we have been the victims of
this
you have also insinuated that there was
foreign meddling or influence in the
elections and in the elections you
defended the harassment of certain
journalists
um journalists that were vilified by the
government at the time so on behalf of
my group prime minister I'd like to
assure you that you have the support of
most of the MEPS here
and you are determined to support and
encourage a calm political debate in
your country and my group very much
hopes that Slovenia will be at the heart
of Europe and that the path of the
Slovenian people have chosen will
inspire other European people such as
the people of Poland and Hungary and you
have the support of renew Europe thank
you I give the floor now to Philip
Lambert the co-chair of the green group
the Prime Minister welcome welcome to
the European Parliament it's good to
hear sincere words of uh I would say a
decent person who is in politics we have
at least two things in common I started
my career in the private sector as well
for 22 years
and what made me enter politics was the
fact that in my municipality the same
party adult majority absolute majority
for 65 years they considered power as
their property
and this is why I said well I need to
step in because a former prime minister
in Belgium once said you know politics
once all the disgusted people will have
left only the disgusting one will remain
and so we don't want this to happen so
welcome and it's uh such a relief
to see Slovenia under your leadership
stopping the slippery slope and
reversing the slippery slope on which it
was we are witnessing within the
European Union enough of trampling on
rule of law and European values not to
see it happen in one more member State
and that was exactly what was happening
in Slovenia so for all this thank you
I'm really happy that you are there I
have also
been touched by the fact that you have
been tearing down fences you know Asylum
and migration are serious challenges but
you understand that indeed it is beyond
the capabilities of any single member
state to find a solution certainly not
with barbed wire and that we need common
response to that in solidarity with each
other and again for that thank you now
use you said a lot about energy and
about the green transition and of course
there's a lot with which we agree you
are remarkable because you are the first
head of government that I hear saying
asserting that there is speculation on
the energy Market you know when I engage
with the commission on that their answer
is no no no the price reflects Market
fundamentals and only Market
fundamentals and yes we have to go after
that I totally agree with that now is
the price cap the best way well maybe
there are other Financial regulation
instruments like position limits and and
curbing the entry into Market of some
players that we need to activate and
there we are totally your allies on this
now on the green transition I know that
you you feel that this is absolutely
crucial to our future you you do not
present that just as a defensive thing
but also an ambitious thing and I agree
with that but they I might have some
questions to you because well my my
friends in Slovenia tell me for instance
that uh the red tape to install solar
panels on roofs in a country where
basically most people have their own
house uh the all these red tape has not
been cut yet also that you want to
prolong uh the extinction of this
hostile based search time uh Power Plant
uh three more years until 20 uh 33 and
then there's the issue of nuclear now we
can have a debate about nuclear energy
but again this is presented in Slovenia
as the Silver Bullet that will solve all
problems in energy really I mean if the
business case for nuclear is so good it
shouldn't be afraid of Affair and square
competition into public debate with
other forms of energy and indeed you
mentioned Renewables and there we would
like a more balanced public debate on
that another thing that you didn't
mention but where Slovenia is strong I
think your country is probably the
European champion of biodiversity I
understand that
uh the the per capita your country is
the most beekeepers uh in Europe so I
don't understand why Slovenia is not
more proactive in supporting the uh
sustainable use of pesticide regulation
because you you know that there's a lot
of resistance and we need support
including in the council not just in the
parliament to make it happen so prime
minister a lot to agree with uh frankly
we want to work with you and uh well
let's hope that indeed what you are
doing in Slovenia is not just a
parenthesis but the beginning of a new
future so thank you glad to work with
you thank you thank you very much I give
the floor now to France Jamie on behalf
of the ID group
wait
is
one in Three French people giving up
Medical Care
11 million French people suffering
currently
our company is moving abroad
Brussels imposing a reform of retirement
age
companies small companies going to the
wall
and farmer suicides every other day
fishermen beings sacrificed
the French are in the dark and shivering
our nuclear sector has been sacrificed
by and sabotaged by Brussels to deprive
us of our energy security we have a
climate of recession
uh alongside massive immigration that's
what the that's what Europe is uh Mr
seizure now where our compatriots live
Europe is Brussels and technocracy and
globalization that's your Europe you can
have it
our Europe
our Europe is the power of the people
our Europe is a Europe of Nations that
have taken us through the centuries with
diversity and progress and given us
influence across the world that's the
Europe we defend with economic
patriotism and respect for the economic
sovereignty of Nations
uh Europe is not the European Union they
are fundamentally irreconcilable
but you can be sure that it's our Europe
that will survive however when you have
a prime minister of a country that you
could engage with that you don't use
this opportunity to do exactly that on
behalf of the ECR group I now write
ladies love Ilitch to take the floor
well
Croatia and Slovenia are neighboring and
very friendly countries I hope that
slovenes will
root for Croatia this evening
uh I have two questions so one concerns
a topic you didn't touch on in your
speech and that is security and rule of
law in the context of illegal migration
the EU is at a turning point there are
those within the EU who Advocate a
responsible approach and border control
sending a message to migrants that they
shouldn't even try to cross the border
illegally because they will not succeed
and then they will avoid doing that we
have a lot of humanitarian disasters
there are those who Advocate a soft
approach sending a message to migrants
well come
ill managed across the border somehow
they're not only sending out this
message but they're saying not only that
it's possible to cross the border
illegally but that they will help them
to do so
you can see for example
things such as the Viking ship in Europe
where there is an active cooperation
between these organizations and the
people Smugglers so my question is will
you help in the responsible protection
of the Schengen borders and how will you
contribute to
safeguarding our common border
especially with respect to the
resignation of Tatiana bobnerio a
previous
Minister for internal affairs you also
spoke a lot about energy and energy
shortages I think it's already clear
that this started to have happened even
before the aggression of Russia against
Ukraine in the EP we have
an approach to which we call Green and
ambitious but very often it's not that
it's actually counterproductive we would
ban everything we would ban a coal gas
we would Advocate heat pumps and allow
gases in heat pumps and so on
you invested a vast sum of 500 million
euros in
financing holding but it's not clear
what you will support this holding
includes the
thermal power plant and the nuclear
power plant Kershaw this is the joint
ownership of Croatia and the Slovenia
how do you see this transition of course
we need a green transition but we have
to see how realistic it is how fast it
can proceed and how you you see the
inclusion of Croatia into new projects
thank you
prime minister welcome
as a CEO a company leader who stepped
quickly into prime minister shoes
fantastic perhaps I could pick up on
something which you didn't really talk
about when you spoke
social dumping so prime minister you're
aware of what social dumping is this is
when
employees workers
are re-employed as part of long chains
of suppliers with a whole series of
intermediaries
temporary work agencies sent to foreign
countries where they work under awful
conditions for lower wages
all of that is part of what the European
Union calls the free moved from to
services
and this social dumping
involves major differences when it comes
to gross pay and National Insurance
contributions so they Define wages and
contributions to the basis of the
country where the contract was signed
rather than the way the work's being
done for companies this is obviously
very beneficial they can maximize
profits while reducing the national
insurance payments they pay for workers
this is of course
a disaster
we've had very scandalous examples
recently in Antwerp in Belgium which
shows that this trend is becoming even
worse where non-european workers are now
being shamelessly exploited they're sent
via hungry and Portugal to Antwerp in
Belgium
social dumping you know all about that
we have that in the transport and
building sectors as well as many other
parts of the economy
promise to your own country often plays
a major role in this whole process
such a major role in fact that the etuc
the European trade unions Confederation
has recently started legal proceedings
against Slovenia
possibly under pressure from larger
countries
which encourage them to do that however
I've looked at the figures
approximately one-third of workers in
the Slovenian building industry have
been sent to work abroad that's the
highest percentage for the whole of the
EU if these uh detached workers
are from Slovenia some of them actually
workers from non-eu Members this means
that companies set up in Slovenia go
overseas to seek workers not because
they need them but simply to dispatch
them immediately to other member states
where they then can be cruelly exploited
so as to maximize the profits of the
companies in question while at the same
time undermining employment legislation
and calculations suggest that this leads
to fraud involving 128 billion euros
that's what we call a social hold up and
that's just one country
so just a few years ago under the
previous government in Slovenia I went
there and had a meeting with trade
unionists and they told me something
which I found quite shocking they told
me that in the minutes of the building
which houses the ministry
you have
a whole series of letterbox companies
in other words one office with an
endless list of companies which are in
theory based there but which do nothing
whatsoever in that building but this is
a building which belongs to the ministry
prime minister social dumping whether by
seconding workers or social dumping is a
real problem in Europe we all know there
are solutions to this problem
for example free movement of services
must come with conditions fundamental
guarantees regarding labor equal work
for equal pay a rejection of any type of
discrimination between workers depending
on where their contract was signed
and of course a European directive on
limiting uh subcontracting chains which
are an open door for social dumping so
one question to you prime minister what
will your government do
change the role that Slovenia plays in
this process of social dumping
colleagues prime minister of our
neighboring and friendly Republic of
Croatia in the name of our friendship I
would like to ask you two things first
please give us some advice
how did you manage to produce
14 million vehicles
sorry you produce 45 year calls per hour
one vehicle every minute and we in the
Republic of Croatia with billions of
public money have managed to produce
only a few of them
so give us some advice secondly I ask
you as I ask all my colleagues to root
for Croatia this evening and on Sunday
we have a final
for the European Union and for all of us
to be glad about it so long live the
European Union
thank you and I give the flow to Ramana
Thompson for three minutes
thank you for giving me the flow
dear prime minister Dr Robert golop I
was interested in listening to your
speech where you talked about the energy
crisis the green transition and the
enlargement process to the Western
Balkans region I am happy to have heard
proposals on how to tackle these issues
and I would be even happier if you had
solutions for Slovenia as well because
the situation is dire in our country
next to the questions connected to the
rising prices the rule of law is also
endangered and media Freedom thousands
of people in Slovenia have after six
months of your government been left
without a doctor the citizens are paying
one of the highest prices for energy in
Europe they are worried how next to the
rising inflation they will survive the
winter in the economy there have been
warnings that you that your measures are
too slow too complex and not efficient
enough
a few days ago as has been said the
interior Minister
has stood down and accused you to have
meddled in the police where you have
called for certain people to be
dismissed in the National Parliament you
have lied to the members your past and
present role when it comes to energy
transactions is filled with unanswered
questions
the president president of the European
Parliament
the president of the national Parliament
has been a
comparing policemen to inappropriate
person the media
have been exposed to threats and
pressures from Young government it is
clear
that you are using autocratic measures
yesterday
one of the co-founders of your party has
resigned from it and it is clear that
there are people who do not agree with
your measures you are trying to come to
power in all institutions and try to
silence the media that have been
critical to your dealings unfortunately
your actions at home do not show what
you are talking abroad
it is difficult to reach you because you
are protected by media and political
activists what you are doing is far from
democracy and it is not consistent with
European values unfortunately the
citizens of Slovenia will be the ones to
bear the consequences brutal intrusions
in the media landscape should worry the
European institutions if I come back to
your speech we would wish that all you
have said to the European public would
be done in Slovenia as well however
words are not enough people expect
concrete measures that will allow them
efficient health care and help when
dealing with high energy prices but
instead of that taxes have been uh
brought up they
expect a free media landscape the
economy needs measures immediately not
next winter and we all expect for you to
respect the rule of law and to stop
destroying democracy and setting up an
authority authoritarian system in
Slovenia
India prime minister
Dr Robert golope
welcome in Strasbourg welcome in the
European Parliament welcome Among Us it
is nice to hear Slovenian language being
spoken in this Parliament I would like
to thank you for being so engaged when
dealing with Bosnia and herzegovino and
trying to ensure this country gets
candidate status as soon as possible I
believe that the slovene politicians
have been crucial when trying to ensure
the candidate's status to Bosnia and
Herzegovina including the president of
our Republic the foreign minister and US
Emmy peace
on my Initiative for Madam president of
the European Parliament received a
letter where we have called for ensuring
the parliament calls for Bosnia and
Herzegovina to be given the candidate's
status
considering the times we're living in
considering the horrific war in Europe
this is uh crucial if not key step for
the entire Western Balkans region this
is a region that often loses its
ambition and power to try to come closer
to the EU this is a region that was
promised the European perspective almost
20 years ago by the European Union at
the Thessaloniki Summit but it seems
that we are still far away from a new
enlargement process
there are strong connections between
Slovenia and Boston and Herzegovina and
also other states in the western Balkans
region we are tied by Common history
website by friendships Slovenia is and
will be an ally of the western Balkans
countries without any conditions without
games and without harmful interests
today we are two days before the
December Summit and the
has been given green light by the
commission so I call upon you to give
the green light at the European Summit
as well it should be heard clearly EU de
facto lives its mission to ensure a
connected Europe and Western Balkans
region should become an equal partner in
it
dear prime minister I would like to ask
you how do you see the possibility that
Bosnian Herzegovina will be given the
candidate status which country still
presents the most problems in the region
is compromised possible and what message
would the EU like to send to the other
countries in the region thank you very
much thank you very much our next
speaker is Madame Catalina
foreign
thank you very much prime minister for
addressing this chamber today and
sharing your vision for the future of
Europe a vision that I was so pleased to
hear in this chamber
protecting our European values standing
up for the rule of law facing the
climate emergency with courage and
ambition our group renew Europe is
wholeheartedly behind you in the fight
for these issues it's so important but
also as a representative of the
Hungarian momentum movement the youngest
opposition party fighting uh Victor
orban's a liberal populism I also wanted
to talk briefly about what I believe
this year's election in Slovenia mean
for us and also for Europe as the whole
the government of former prime minister
Jana zienza alarmed Europe and
rightfully so it has shown that no
country is immune to democratic
backsliding Mr rienza issued as dominant
attacks as members of this Parliament
and against members of our group in
particular at home he attacked civil
liberties undermine judicial
Independence media Freedom was very
severely curtailed as Hungarian media
tycoons showed up in Slovenia interfere
and with press freedom and exporting the
urban model so in short what we saw is
the organization of Slovenia The
Playbook was just so remarkably similar
and this is why the election victory of
the Freedom Movement has such a broad
europe-wide importance
first and foremost it gave us hope
hope that the global Democratic
backsliding Trend can be stopped and it
can be reversed that the values of
liberal democracy and environmentalism
can Prevail against illiberal populism
also electorally
but colleagues the steady erosion of her
European values and the trend of
democratic backsliding did not stop and
we're also still hear talking points of
one of the autocrats echoed by major
political groups in this house there is
so much work to be done for the European
Union as a whole to defend our values so
I believe that the new government in
Slovenia has a very deep understanding
but also a strong credibility to stand
up for European values one great
priority must be media freedom and a
strong eu-wide regulation for media
markets we are looking forward to your
leadership on this issues prime minister
thank you
thank you for our colleague
thank you
speaker is Thomas lights
the commissioner the Prime Minister
Robert golopa first a short comment that
our conservative colleagues a
geographically uh Paulo Angel Slovenia
is an Alpine Republic uh and uh to the
former speaker from yancho's party it
was your government leaving a devastated
Health Care system to your successor so
don't blame the new government for your
failures but now coming to my actual
speech thank you so much for coming to
the European Parliament and congrats
once again for securing a progressive a
pro-european a liberal
democracy-oriented majority in my so
dear to my heart neighboring and uh also
partly a living country Slovenia thank
you so much for that and also I want to
personally thank you for your strong
support for the integration of Western
Balkan countries towards European Union
it's very important to have you as one
of the pillars of further negotiations
we need to accelerate we need to keep
our promises it's important for the
citizens but it's also important in
terms of security economy and
environment so thank you very much for
that indeed I also have a critical
question that I would like to ask you
and this is especially towards you as an
energy expert you you know that nuclear
energy takes long to be built you know
that it is causing a harm to environment
you know that karishko is built on an
earthquake line on a geological instable
uh region and and you know that
renewable energy is much cheaper and
much more effective than nuclear energy
please explain to us why do you want to
build the second block while Slovenia
has all the options on the table to go
for solar and please also tell us how
you will enable households to also
deliver electricity to the system and
not just Supply themselves thank you
very much
thank you
very much
could you oh please stick to your times
we need to start our vote on time our
next speaker is not there so we move on
to Mr Brzezinski
go ahead do you have the floor
thank you president prime minister
I would like to thank you to what you
said to us in this chamber it's very
important that when talking about the
future of Europe in the European
Parliament
that the voice must be heard from people
from Central
Europe
on many occasions we have heard from the
so-called old European Union that
countries such as czechos Slovakia
Poland Hungary
our countries who are allowed less
because supposedly our democracies are
not as developed as the so-called
developed democracies in Germany France
or the Netherlands and what we get as a
result is what we see in the case of the
war in Ukraine you failed to listen to
those who knew what Russia is or was
under charts or under the Bolsheviks or
under Putin recently luckily today also
EU institution people are saying well
too bad we didn't listen to Poland so
prime minister in your speech
there are things that I agree with 100
such as
enlargement in Western Balkans that's
obvious that if we turn our backs on
Bosnia and Herzegovina then sooner or
later they will fall under the influence
on of Russia or the the sauds but some
of the uh things you said are something
that I find skeptical
veg being vegetarian or the climate
religion
that would make everyone's happy well
I'm skeptical on that
some of the previous speakers were quite
hypocritical
if you come from the right political
Club then you're okay if you're from the
outside then you're the bad guy you
endanger democracy and uh but you can
see that it's not always as obvious as
it would be as we see the from the
current corruption Scandal thank you
foreign
thank you president prime minister thank
you for your inspiring vision on energy
food freedom for uh what it represents
for Europe Slovenia has made an
extraordinary Journey since it became an
independent state and especially since
it's joined the European Union
today is a model in many ways and I
believe it can help the Union as a whole
at a time of very high risks which have
been aggravated by the Russian
aggression against Ukraine
Slovenia can help make people understand
that Europe as a strength lies in the
diversity of its people and that the
more diverse we are the more efficient
we are
that we can ensure the well-being of
citizens in a more effective and
sustainable way and that we can better
ensure fundamental rights
respect for this diversity is the key of
the future of the union and in this
sense of Slovenia as you mentioned has a
very important role to play thank you
very much
that's it please do try and stick to
your speaking time our next speaker is
Sean Kelly
margotron thank you prime minister for
joining us today to show you views on
the future of Europe
I welcome you to this timely debate
we are currently at a critical juncture
for Europe and for European democracy
facing significant challenges brought
internally and externally
looking internally events within the
European Parliament over the recent days
have shaken our trust in our Institution
allegations come to light of possible
corruption cases involving MEPS and
Parliament staff are deeply troubling
there is no place for corruption in
European democracy and these
developments will warrant a period of
deep reflection and reform
beyond our Greenery chamber we are
facing unprecedented challenges in
Europe
war in Ukraine and the ensuing energy
and cost living crisis pose new tests
for the EU and called for the
cooperation between member states
as Citizens and business Warrior this
Christmas about keeping the lights and
heating on we must ensure that the EU
continues to deliver for its citizens
Unity is more important than ever
as leader with small European member
State I am confident that you understand
this prime minister
Ireland and Slovenia are alike in
disregard
a small member states we share a common
understanding
that together we are stronger than apart
indeed Slovenia joined the European
Union during Ireland's Council
presidency in 2004.
having witnessed the enormous benefits
that European union membership has
delivered from my country in terms of
economic social and cultural
opportunities
it was a pleasure to hear that Aaron
played this small role in slovenia's
Journey
looking forward the shared challenges we
now face are significant
no single country can handle these alone
that a huge strength in unity and I hope
to continue to see Slovenia and Ireland
grow together within the EU
thank you very much our next speaker is
thank you chair and welcome to the
European Parliament I appreciate this
opportunity to have a dialogue and I saw
you spoke from your heart we all know
the greetings of the past government the
answer's government and we are so happy
that only in five months and 12 days you
have delivered not everything can be
changed but you see the government
building the common Europe and showing
that the small country can play an
active role on Way Forward on the
transition that is so important even in
the time of the crisis your greetings on
the energy systems I could not agree
more it's needs to be a clean transition
and we need to get rid of the
speculators on the markets and this day
when the people are seeing the prices of
energy also your government was will put
a lot of help for their citizens
dear colleagues I think what we heard
today also on the importance of rule of
law it may not be unanswered that we can
send greetings to the Slovenian
Parliament thank you for giving the
same-sex marriage rights also citizens
in uh Slovenia as we have worked here
for the rule of law it's important
international government is doing the
very same thing
[Applause]
can I please ask colleagues as they come
into the room to keep their voices down
it ends of about two minutes we will
have to be tight on time because we're
running late thanks
Kuala LIPA
thank you dear prime minister dear
colleagues
in the past seven decades the European
Union has grown from a political project
of Peace into an actual political
Community together we are setting Global
standards for the people we are setting
standards when it comes to climate
policy digital rights healthy food and
Democratic Values is everything perfect
no
while European Union has been evolving
politically the bureaucratic machine has
been growing as well and it is now too
complex adapting with great difficulty
to constant new challenges and crises in
the past years we have made big steps
that is of course true for example in
our climate policy and the recovery and
resilience fund but where are we today
today we are living in the reality
forged by the criminal war in Ukraine
the energy and the energy crisis and
despite all efforts and achievements I
do miss higher ambition level at the
level of the EU and in other areas I
would also wish for us to be more united
when we are responding to the
consequences of the crisis and when
you're setting the common framework for
the green Investments that are needed to
ensure European energy independency we
are setting a good basis with repower EU
common purchases of gas and limiting the
electricity prices but but in these days
we're also talking about an unfair
American anti-inflation act so we should
also find the political power political
will to respond as Europe for example to
set up a new flexible fund to do for
dealing with crisis
vetoes in the council are forcing the
council to make compromises that are
inadmissible and the corruption at a
systemic level
in member states and then also in this
Parliament is eating away our
credibility so that is why we need
institutional reforms and for that we
need to open up the treaties do away
with unanimity democratize our processes
and ensure uh public narrative
one minute
thank you dear prime minister golop uh
last year I had the opportunity to visit
Slovenia on a mission as a member of the
budgetary control committee under your
predecessary anesians Slovenia was
suffering multiple rule of law crisis
the issue that resonated with me mostly
was the intimidation of the controlling
authorities as well as the lack of media
Freedom budgets were cut and critical
investigative journalists were victims
of organized attacks and of course we
can't forget uh his efforts to
politicize your radio broadcaster radio
television Slovenia
but you are the head of a new government
and I hear that the situation has
improved already uh and your legislative
initiative to restructure the governing
bodies of radio television Slovenia is a
welcome one
I hope that it will indeed lead to a
less hostile public media landscape
however it appears that there are some
branches of the government where the
political influence is still creeping uh
back in so recently we have witnessed
your interior Minister resigned over the
uh thank you Mr fixer So yeah thank you
thank you very much next is for one and
a half minutes
foreign
distinguished
the president you represented crisis not
even the war in the Ukraine that doesn't
stop the green uh social Democrats or
the red of
right-wing to implement really crazy
decisions why can't we freeze uh our
emission trade this would be a very good
way of lowering electricity prices if we
do not use peat almost all in Finland
anymore and now we're complaining when
central heating is so expensive do you
want electricity to be expensive or
cheap if you want it to be cheap
I wonder if it would now be a good time
to change the way we are thinking we
have parasites green parasites overall
the journalists in the media are green
mostly and that's why this is why the
income comes from lying
uh
this craziness does not stop here
we are told
now that we have a 72 different uh
genders and other nonsense like that we
do not talk in favor of the persecuted
Christians even though they are the most
important group in the world I'm very
concerned about the West it's in danger
of sinking
[Applause]
for one minute please what do you mean
prime minister some of our colleagues
are not here with us today because they
are sleeping in jail staff members
several members of the European
Parliament are Under Suspicion of
corruption having been paid by Qatar to
influence EU policy they all came from
the bleeding heart left all of them are
the mouthpieces of ngos who purport to
lecture people and governments that have
been legitimately elected on what is
good and right I've been a member for
eight years now and I have been
subjected to session after session
report after report lecture I've seen
them all gloat about virtue and human
rights
and now we learn that the homophobe
Hunters got bags of cash from home from
the homophobe State par Excellence yes
this hypocrisy this dysplicity could
make us laugh but this corruption case
should make us wonder how many speeches
have been teleprompted by the Qatari
money how many texts have been voted
here by S D even last month were
promoted by the interests of the
islamist government when an EU campaign
promotes the headscarf is that coming
from Brussels or from Doha
enough naivety enough weakness in this
in the face of this Islamic offensive
let us reaffirm our values in the face
of this treachery Bay now with bogus
love liberatsky for one minute
[Applause]
thank you madam president
prime minister
let me say I totally with you and
welcome back on the right track
you said you must be decisive unity and
more I understood power and another
European methodology and also I am
totally with you
renewable energy it means own resources
using waste biomass Sun wind new jobs
cheaper energy and energy Independence
rule of law I'm coming from Poland I am
totally with you rural of law is not to
be negotiated is to be enforced and
thank you for your words concerning
Ukraine supporting Ukraine it means we
are preserving our freedom and peace and
at the end I am keeping fingers crossed
for your game against Argentina tonight
thank you
for one minute
thank you president prime minister
in 1991 U.S Secretary of State James
Baker solemnly declared that neither the
United States nor the European Community
would ever recognize an independent
Slovenia less than a year later both
were among the first to recognize the
new country
the lesson is simple self-determination
must be pursued regardless of the
opposition of world powers that always
will protect the status quo this also
means that states only recognize the
exercise of this right when it suits
them geopolitically or when they think
that rejecting it causes more trouble
than accepting yeast and that's why it
often becomes a mess and a source of
instability the EU should change
instance on self-determination and Grant
a safe and clear path for minorities to
exercise it within the union and for
doing it with the rest of the world
we'll help you in this endeavor thank
you next is Robert Heisel for one minute
thank you very much chair uh thank you
Mr Prime Minister the colleagues
I think Slovakia is an example for all
for the Western Vulcans who are striving
for EU membership so it is good that a
lot of time and effort is being put into
this region we have seen the Russian
invasion in Ukraine that has really
changed the geopolitical situation
membership to the EU means security it
means more stability in the neighboring
countries to the EU that is very
important the Balkans have long aimed to
have membership alongside uh we have
botany we have Serbia
we recently had The Summit in Tirana
this place I think it has led to
increased optimism in these countries
I think it is good
that we can mutually help each other
thank you
president
thank you madam president Mr golub
it's a great honor for us to be here in
the chamber today to have this debate
with you
just one year ago Slovenia set out on a
path of destruction
led by the then prime minister against
the media of the country and this
Judiciary he showed enormous arrogance
in doing this I'm delighted to see that
Slovenia quickly moved away from that
model I'm congratulate you having
initiated ambitious reforms to ensure
that your country be secure from all
political interference
what you've done to reinstate political
and individual Freedom should be a model
for the whole of Europe
uh Mr goodop thank you for having
brought Sylvania back to the heart of
the European Union and above all for
proving that Southeastern Europe is in a
position to put forward reforms which
can act as a source of inspiration to
the whole of the Union thank you the
floor to prime minister golub can I ask
you dear colleagues to show respect to
heads of state and government when they
come and address this Parliament and
this is Europe debates prime minister
you have the floor
[Applause]
dear members of the parliament
the Roberta
glad to be here again now I have a
bigger audience now
obviously enjoyed my you enjoyed my
previous speech so much you came to
listen All of You
but let me
let me reiterate
certain things that are so important
that I don't want to I want you to miss
first
let me pledge our fool not just support
but commitment to implementation of rule
of law in Slovenia but also our support
to rule of law within the other member
states in the European Union as such
and rule of law is not subject to
interpretation
of political
partisans it is something that you
either have or you don't
because it's not just a political system
it is our responsibility to implement
but it's being lived by other
subsystems as media a judicial system
and so forth
the other commitment
that I would like to pledge fully is our
commitment to support Ukrainian people
we've done everything possible
and everything that we could or even did
not plan to do Under the previous
government
we are supporting Ukraine in all
possible ways
and we do it promptly
we are not just
promising eight we are delivering eight
promptly
and that's something that's easily
very easily to be proved
we are also very committed to support
the enlargement of European Union in the
western Balkans this is one of the first
topics on our government agenda
when it comes to foreign policy we want
to see the region stable
and the only way to stabilize the region
is by bringing it closer to integrate it
to European Union
it's not a matter of which mechanism is
being used it's about integration
and as fast as possible and the
strongest the possible
that's the only way how we can transform
the region
at its core
and third it comes to energy
I believe that no
no single nation can face the energy
crisis alone it doesn't matter how big
you are it doesn't matter how rich you
are
the cost you will pay if you want to
tackle it alone is going to be
exorbitant and you will not be able to
take it
maybe for a year yes but not on a longer
run
The Only Way Forward is through United
and coordinated effort
and this for this particular reason I
urge again not just you but my
colleagues
forget about National
egoistical moves thinking that you can
solve your problems and leaving the
others behind it's not doable
the The Only Way Forward is by being
united and decisive
it is truly The Only Way Forward
and it's all only and it's and that is
also the only
possible message that the speculative
traders who are ruling the energy
markets of Europe right now will
understand and let's lift the floor with
that
[Applause]
thank you very much prime minister
we move now to the votes but I
understand there's a point of order to
be made by Mr blasko heinek first
please state the rule under which you
are making it
under rule 195 please allow me to raise
a point of order Madam president
somebody here posted a disgusting
picture on the opposite on the office
door of my office
this is an example of completely
unacceptable pressure
when it's perfectly comparable to people
who call it on social networks for
citizens to
attack people of different views
similarly
the drawing up of lists of such people
and references to internment
we are supposed to be living according
to European values such people should be
ashamed of themselves first of all we
will vote on a proposal from the
conference of presidents
for the early termination of the office
of our vice president of the European
Parliament Miss Eva Kylie
in accordance with Rule 21 The Proposal
requires for adoption a majority of
two-thirds of the votes cast
constituting a majority of parliament's
component members only votes for and
against constitute votes cost for the
purposes of calculating whether the
necessary two-thirds majority has been
obtained in accordance with rule 187
paragraph three please note that the
total displayed at the top of the screen
will include abstentions and that the
votes taken into account are only the
votes for and against we shall now
proceed with the vote by Rojo and the
vote is open
foreign